a lot of people still struggling to
catch up on rent and mortgage following
the pandemic and still right now that's
why there is a new cdc eviction
moratorium
for now it expires october 3rd unless
legal challenges send it sooner it's
aimed at preventing tenants from being
kicked out of their homes in areas that
are
high risk for covet 19 clark county is
one of those areas
it's important to note though that the
moratorium extension does not mean
tenants still
don't have to take action we're
always trying to warn tenants don't
ignore a notice i know it's tempting
you're stressed out
don't ignore it there's health available
so if you are facing eviction the legal
aid center of southern nevada has an
eviction prevention hotline
their number 702-386-1070
the center will be offering free
eviction clinics over the next few weeks
the first one
is on saturday august 14th at the
neighborhood rec
center from 9 a.m to noon we have
resources available on our website as
well
8newsnow.com